Bah plutôt en semaine.
Oui.
Dites nous où se trouve le coffre !
Tu vas nous dire où il est ton coffre !
Attends, juste un truc.
Dites nous où se trouve le coffre.
Dites nous où se trouve le coffre !
Ton flingue...
C'est un faux.
Ok.
T'avais qu'une balle dans ton chargeur.
Très bien.
T'avais deux balles dans ton char...
Ok !
Il est derrière le lavabo, dans la salle de bain.
Je voulais pas tirer hein.
Dites nous où se trouve le coffre !
Quoi ?
J'ai pas de coffre.
Arrêtes de faire le malin avec nous sinon ça va mal finir, ok ?!
Je vous jure j'ai pas de coffre ici.
Oui. Il dit qu'il a pas de coffre chez lui.
Pourtant on est bien au 19, comme on avait dit.
Au 19 bis !
Vous êtes au 19 bis !
Ah ! Oui, pardon bah on s'est gourés.
Ah merde, le vase du coup...
Je vous laisse... 100 balles en dédommagement.
Je suis désolé.
Attendez !
Je vous rends la monnaie parce que je l'ai payé que 94 euros.
Dites nous où se trouve le coffre !
J'ai pas de coffre.
Tu vas nous dire où il est ton coffre !
J'en ai pas, je suis mal organisé.
J'ai tout dans la chambre, sous mon matelas.
Si vous voulez j'ai environ un demi million d'euros.
C'est là-bas.
Ouais mais nous...
On est venus pour le coffre !
Je comprends pas ce que vous voulez.
Vous pouvez aller acheter un coffre en vite fait ?
Dites nous où se trouve le coffre !
C'est quoi ?
C'est la clé du coffre ?
Il vient d'avaler la clé du coffre.
Mais comment on va faire ?
D'accord, c'est un magicien.
Oh ouais c'est naze.
J'irai pas le voir hein.
Dites nous où se trouve le coffre !
J'étais au téléphone.
Donc tu serais dispo vendredi ?
Pour voir une pièce de Tchekhov.
Bah tu m'en vois ravi.
Bisous ti coeur.
C'est bon ?
Dites nous où se trouve le...
Oui, maman ?
Dites nous où se trouve le coffre !
Apparement je pense que je me suis trompé.
Ah si, si !
De quoi ?
Ouais.
C'est pour moi. Faites la glisser.
Y a pas de sauce piquante ?
Dites nous où se trouve la sauce piquante !
Éric ?
C'est toi ?
Non.
Mais si, je te reconnais Éric.
C'est quoi ? C'est une blague que tu me fais là ?
Non je confirme c'est pas Éric.
Je suis pas Éric mec.
C'est quoi ? C'est filmé ? Y a des invités, c'est ça ?
Mais non. Je suis pas Éric !
Voilà maintenant j'ai ton visage !
Je file au commissariat pour leur montrer la photo !
Ouais mais il crois que je suis Éric.
Il sais pas que je m'appelle Christian donc c'est bon.
Ok maintenant je sais que tu t'appelles Christian, je vais leur dire aussi !
T'es cheum en vrai.
Dites nous où se trouve le coffre !
Attendez, vous venez de me vouvoyer là ?
Vous me donnez quel âge ?
Je sais pas...
34 ?
J'ai 28 ans.
Mais attention, je suis toujours jeune hein !
Vous croyez que je suis pas cap de faire des trucs de foufou ?
Bah on a rien dit nous monsieur.
Tu crois que je suis pas cap de faire des trucs de foufou ?
Si, si, si.    - Si, si, si.
Venez on va braquer la banque en bas.
Allez go ! Go ! Go ! Go ! Go !
Un poil trop foufou pour moi le gars.
En plus il a toujours l'air vieux quoi.
C'est juste un vieux avec un fusil.